we are back on Dead Doctors Don't Lie
with our guest host today Dr Peter Glen
Philly good for Dr wallik welcome back
Dr Glen hey hey hey Doug let's set them
up and knock him down all right let's
head to Atlanta Georgia and Jay you're
on with Dr glinton hey Dr glinton uh
recently my wife uh had some blood work
done last week and the numbers came back
that she had a
hyperthyroid and uh hyper
hyper hyper is it
hyper yeah high thyroid all right very
good okay um and it's interesting
because I've been listening to your
program the whole time and um I think
basically we're probably going to answer
the question uh just through what you've
been telling your other um listeners but
um it's interesting because last week um
the day after my wife back she
absolutely refused the radiation they
that's what they
recommended and we decided we wanted to
go to a natural route well the next day
my friend called me and talked to me
about Dr wallet interestingly enough and
uh anyway we signed up uh we ordered our
products and um basically one of the
reasons why I'm calling is we just got
the product today plus um we got um the
ocean gold and also the drops of balance
to um specifically Target her thyroid
and I guess I wanted to ask you if that
was the way you would go and also other
than the the 90 Essentials and giving
the body time to heal itself would you
recommend anything else that we could do
from a a natural standpoint well yeah
has a lot of things you can do so with
an overactive thyroid she needs to be
eating a lot of cruciferous veget she
needs to be eating broccoli cauliflower
eggplant brussels sprouts uh spinach she
needs to be eating that stuff every day
and lots of it because that has uh
naturally
occurring uh uh plant hormones in them
phyto chemicals in them that depress
thyroid function right so it's a really
smart thing to do when you have an
overactive thyroid to take a bunch of uh
food into the body that suppresses
thyroid function and that's the easiest
way to do it is with the cruci fous
vegetables broccoli cauliflower eggplant
brussels sprouts and spinach okay number
one number two she needs to go to a
chiropractor have her neck x-rayed from
the side and make sure the curve in her
neck is correct because the nerves that
go to her thyroid come out of the neck
and if the curve in her neck is not
anatomically correct the nerve function
is going to be messed up going to the
thyroid and so you need to make sure
that the neck is structurally sound in
order to to have optimal thyroid
function because if it's not I don't
care how many supplements she takes I
don't care how good her diet is her
thyroid is going to be funky just
because her neck is not on her shoulders
properly so go to a chiropractor have
them check the curve in her neck to make
sure it's good and if it's not the
chiropractor can give her exercises that
will in fact put the curve back the way
that nature intended it to that's number
two third thing to do is make sure that
you have enough a selenium
into the program because the thyroid
needs three things to function optimally
it needs iodine selenium and copper you
can get iodine from using iodized table
salt and that's what she should be using
I don't care if it's sea salt or
Himalayan salt or good oldfashioned
Morton's iodized table salt it has to
have iodine added to it all right so if
you use sea salt make sure it says with
iodine or iodized okay you have to be
using iodized salt with every meal so
that while you know not with uh you know
puffed rice but you use salt on food
that calls for salt and use iodized salt
and uh the selenium is appropriate
because the selenium youngevity selenium
thank God for Dr Wallock provides
selenium and copper in the proper ratios
which are two of the three things that
the thyroid needs to optimize its
function the recommendation here would
be one bottle of selenium per 50 pounds
of body weight per month one bottle of
selenium per 50 pounds of body weight
per month uh the drops of balance is a
good thing another good thing to do
would be myrr oil m y r RH you know like
the wise men frankincense and myrr well
myrr oil painted on top of the thyroid
gland will downregulate thyroid function
I would get the myrr oil and paint it
right on top of the thyroid put a couple
drops underneath on my upper lip so then
inhale it take three or four deep
breaths three four times a day with the
oil and immediately before bed so the
recommendation here would be uh the
Healthy Start pack appropriate for body
weight the selenium appropriate for body
weight eliminate the 10 bad foods
increase uh the cruciferous vegetables
in into the bargain and get the neck
x-rayed by a chiropractor and make sure
it's on the body properly if she does
and use the myr oil if she does those
things she should notice a a steady uh
Improvement in thyroid function over
time but remember we don't treat
thyroids we don't treat knees we don't
treat Hearts we don't treat lungs we
don't treat joints we treat people this
is not specifically a thyroid problem
this is a holistic program the intention
of which is to support and promote
everything in your wife's body to fix
itself and optimize its function so as
we're going Downstream here in addition
to paying attention to the you know
whatever the hyperthyroid symptoms are
you also want to see well what the heck
happens to her sleep and her energy and
her appetite and her weight and her
aches and pains and everything because
this is a patently holistic therapeutic
and you should abandon all other
Therapeutics abandon all other
Therapeutics just do this for 90 days
dial it in baby see how it goes and call
us back with a a progress report every
four weeks that sound good Robin Hood it
sure does sounds great thank you all
right hey appreciate the keep up the
good work and remember you are the last
best hope your community members have
for living long Healthy and Wealthy
lives so help us spread Dr Wall's
message of Health recovery through
Medical Nutrition it worked for you now
get out there and pay it forward thanks
so much for the call